[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby I
will be your driver on this journey oh
my goodness I have been teaching so many
classes I almost forgot the name of my
own iconic class don't know if you
notice the pause there that was close
anyways today I am going over some games
from the staff throwdown
that kind of happened a little bit
earlier today and the focus of this
class is actually going to be a little
bit more beginner based because watching
these games today reminded me what it's
like trying to play chess when you're
kind of just starting out you get to
this pretty frustrating point right
where everybody is telling you you know
don't worry so much about strategy all
you have to do is do not blunder your
pieces find tactics practice some
tactics but this advice can be pretty
difficult to follow because if you're
just starting out with chess you kind of
get to a point where if you you know
some opening principles you develop your
pieces and then it sort of becomes this
question of of now what you know people
I've seen just get to this point in the
game and they have no idea what to do
and so they end up losing material or
even blundering because they get kind of
frustrated that it feels like their
moves are just kind of meaningless
they're just kind of not doing anything
constructive you know maybe they're
making one move threats but it's tough
to find something constructive to do
once you get to that middle game and
once you're trying to actually
understand some strategy so I wanted to
go over a few games today talk about
some principles that came up in these
games for these middle games and talked
about what you guys can do at home to
get a little bit better at figuring out
what to do in this middle game so the
first game I wanted to take a look at
here was between a chess associate named
Abby and Vinnie Vinnie not a chess
associate but a talented young kid here
in the st. Louis area part of the Select
chess program a very very experienced
chess player now the wonderful tres
associate Abby has not played a lot of
chess in
her day in fact I I would wager she got
kind of roped into playing this event I
have never really seen her play chess by
choice but he or she is playing chests
let's see how this game went for she
started with one d4 vinny responded with
one d5 we have Bishop f4 Bishop f5 and
III 906 92 be six Knight gf3 from white
knight c6 from black c3 now by white
which is a pretty normal move although
you guys can't see anything I'm doing
alright we got it alright c3 by white so
so far just normal normal developing
moves these are moves that you can kind
of make after let's say just a 10-15
minute lesson where someone has kind of
told you the opening principles right or
even perhaps suggested you that you
should play an opening kind of like the
London system where you just develop
these pieces to these natural squares
with the white pieces and go from there
so so far nothing out of the ordinary by
either player they're obviously not
playing the most critical theory but
they're playing perfectly fine normal
opening moves see three of course in
response knight c6 keeps an eye on this
be for square as well black now played
h6 white plays Bishop e2 black played
Bishop d6 and rather than respond to
this threat white went ahead and Castle
black captured on f4 white captured on
f4 and now black castles and this is the
point in the game where things started
getting a little bit suspect for white
so I wanted to turn it over to you guys
at home ask you what you would want to
kind of be doing here with white in this
position where's the moves that pop into
your head and we can talk a little bit
about how to start formulating plans in
openings like these formulating ideas
finding something useful to do with the
pieces see what you got visualization
practice yes a little bit of blindfold
practice for you but you've got the
board on on your screen now so it's time
to put on your strategic thinking caps
the plan is to not lose Abhinav says
night p3 or 95 no pointer says 95 sure
fair enough fair enough so these are a
one one move ideas here so I'll be
enough could you elaborate on the idea
of night b3 because it doesn't feel like
b3 is your real really your destination
square for that night feels like you're
using b3 to get to somewhere else so if
you could elaborate there are CH wants
to play pawn to c4 I like b4 queenside
attack so you guys are just giving me
kind of one move ideas which is fine but
we're gonna expand upon those a little
bit and talk about how we are coming up
with moves like these because I'm the
chat right now I think is at a pretty
high level for what I'm trying to
achieve with this lecture so they're
coming up with good moose but I want to
get to the root of how you can come up
with moves like these they're not just
pulling them out of thin air they do
have some ideas behind them a beam off
says Knight b3
the idea is to potentially come into the
c5 square so let's talk about a few of
the main ideas that have been suggested
there are some ideas like the move 95
there's some ideas oh and DM has a lot
of great ideas here so the move 95 has
been mentioned the move rook e1 has been
mentioned a4 a5 has actually been
mentioned Knight be 3 to c5 has been
mentioned g3 is also a move that has
been mentioned and even this move c4 in
this move B for all of these moves have
been mentioned and now if you're a
beginner level player it can be kind of
overwhelming in positions like these you
start to ask yourself well how do you
actually come up with these kinds of
blooms you know where where are they
getting these moves from what do they
even do it doesn't look like they really
make make any threats but let's talk
about each of these moves a little bit
they kind of fall into slightly
different categories so there's this
plan with Knight b3 to c5 in this idea
of 95 in this move ricky 1 and what
these all have in common is these are
all piece moves right so we can kind of
break up these ideas into
few different category these piece moves
are with the plan of actually improving
the pieces so it's kind of a weird to
say you know in opening in the opening
we are taught these principles you know
then the pieces are better when they're
developed towards the center so you
sometimes get the impression that once
you develop them you're kind of done
your pieces are as good as they get
they're developed but that's actually
not the case and so people are coming up
with these moves because these are moves
that improve the pieces and there are
certain rules about each piece that you
can start to learn for example nights
while they are doing just fine on their
current squares they're better when they
have squares called out posts so that's
where 95 comes into play due to the way
the opening transpired this V 5 square
has become what's called an outpost for
whites night so like we said with
opening principles which hopefully is
something you kind of know going into
this lecture when you get an outpost for
your night that's even better than just
developing it towards the center because
this outpost is a central outpost and as
we know sorry from opening principles
this is the point pieces are the best
when they're placed in the center and
they control all sorts of squares in
this night control c6 c7 f7 g6 these are
all kind of attacking moves and while
this night is probably not going to want
to jump to any of those squares just yet
it could potentially be used as an
attacker on one of these squares for
example later in the game we might get
more pieces into play we might make more
threats on these squares so ii 5 is
called an outpost for the night so
that's one great way you can improve
your nights on the board
getting them to these squares called
outposts the idea of Nyepi 3 to come to
c5 is another good idea to improve this
d2 night by trying to get it to an
outpost now the problem is b6 is likely
not the worst move in the world for
black here probably black wouldn't want
to play this immediately but if this
night does land on c5 it's always going
to have to think about getting kicked
away by a pawn of course we know let's
say black plays a move tonight here now
b6 we know pawns worth less than Knights
if a knight on one of these strong
outposts can be kicked away by a pawn
and it's not really a good outpost it's
not a permanent home that doesn't mean
it's always bad to go there but it does
mean that the knight usually can't last
there so that's part of the reason why
you'll see players not so quick to push
all of their pawns in the opening they
need it to control squares like these
potential outposts for Knights so those
are some rules about improving the
Knights so improving pieces is a really
good plan and you start to pick up these
ideas like outposts along the way this
is kind of the basics of strategy now
let's talk about this move rookie one
this was actually move that was played
in the game and it is in fact a good
move the reason for that is it improves
the rook the rook is better on a1 than
it is on f1 well how do you know that
well rooks have their own kind of set of
principles set of rules attached to them
rooks on half open files or open files
are really powerful now if you don't
know what that means that means files
these vertical lines on the board half
open files are when one of the pawns has
been removed from the file totally open
files would be if there were no pawns to
block the way on this ePHI layer so if
this other epon was off the board then
the sir could be on an open file and
it's pretty intuitive to see why this
improves the rook well the rook on f1
cannot go anywhere vertically because
the pawn is in the way whereas the
ricany won it now looks at all of these
squares if this bishop were ever to move
out of the way and it's a lot more of a
useful piece now I know we're spending a
lot of time here but this is one of the
key moves right other plans that were
suggested were moves like a4 and a5 the
move c4 and the move g3 so each of these
moves actually has a different idea
associated with it so it's fine to just
play to improve your pieces and in fact
that might be what this position calls
for but you can also play to open things
up or to kind of attack with your pawns
and that is the idea with c4 c4 is
aiming to actually open up more files on
the board
access to more squares for the white
pieces so by playing c4 you're trying to
get rid of this strong pawn on d5 for
example if black were to take Y it would
recapture it back and now that these two
pawns are gone the rook has a really
nice home on c1 like we said a half-open
file where it can put some pressure on
the c7 pawn and this knight from d2 has
come to a really nice square on c4 and
even it can think about going to this
outpost on e5 it comes back to trying to
improve your pieces just a bit so that's
the idea with c4 kind of and if black
were to not take then we might be
putting some pressure on the d5 square
or we might be playing the move
c5 with a similar idea to what we saw
with the move
a4 with the idea of a 5 this move is
simply designed to gain space on the
Queen side of course one of the opening
principles is you should try it and take
space in the opening and this is an idea
that holds true in the middle game you
want to still continue to try and grab
extra space when you can so the move a4
and let's say black doesn't do much you
might follow this up even with a move
like B 4 and a 5 and B 5 and now if you
notice we have so much space on the
Queen side that this night is going to
have to move away to a square like east
7 and now blacks control the center has
very much been lessened by this night
moving away and now that we have all
this space on the Queen side we can once
again think about ideas like playing the
move c4 now once again I probably didn't
play the best moves for black there I
just kind of shuffle back and forth but
this is where these ideas are coming
from so we have this idea to improve the
pieces we have this idea to try and open
files for the rooks we have this idea
with c4 immediately here to try and take
away a defender of this square so we can
improve our Knight to an outpost and we
have the simple moves like rook e1 and
we have moves like a 4 and a 5 designed
to gain space so these are all different
plans you can kind of come up with in a
position like this and that's why I
wanted to look at this position in
particular because there's just so much
here that why
can do now the question of which plan is
correct is actually not the most
important one when you're just starting
out if you're playing moves that have a
purpose that are designed to get you
tangible benefits then you're likely
doing a lot better than your opponent's
when you're just kind of starting out at
this level so that's kind of outside the
scope of this lecture really any of
these moves would be a totally fine
place to start so it's about picking up
these rules on how to improve the pieces
and then finding your way to to make
that actually happen the move I didn't
talk about g3 by the way this is just a
simple improving move generally in chess
it's better to have all your pieces
defended whenever possible there's this
kind of principle that says loose pieces
drop off so when your pieces are loose
that's when they're undefended that's
when they can easily be attacked and if
you have too many pieces that are
undefended sometimes two of them get
attacked at the same time and it gets
really difficult to save both of them so
the move g3 is an improving move because
it defends this pawn on f4 that was
otherwise unprotected that being said we
spent a lot of time there but hopefully
that was pretty instructive so the move
rook e1 comes on the board for white and
once again I'm not upset about this move
at all
it's a move with a purpose which is all
you can really ask now the move Knight
e4 was Benny's choice so Vinnie improves
this Knight to e4 this isn't the worst
move ever in fact it's it's pretty
natural
so noticing that this knight on e4 is on
a really strong centrally placed square
white chose to take on a floor with the
knight which is a fine move this is
another part of basic strategy whenever
a trade is offered you shouldn't always
take it of course but in this case you
can kind of evaluate the trade by saying
okay this legs really strong on the e4
square because we know this is an
outpost for the night it controls a lot
of squares from this central position
meanwhile our knight it's a little bit
difficult to see how to get it into the
game so we're trading off a pretty bad
piece for a pretty good piece on Eve
force so that makes sense it's a logical
trade and now Bishop takes e4
was played in the game and once again
this is the type of position where you
can go many many different directions
but you do want to go in one specific
direction you want to have moves with a
purpose so after Bishop takes e4 there
are a lot of perfectly fine moves that Y
could play here for example ninety five
would be a totally fine move you could
leave this night sitting here the move
g3 is also perfectly fine you could even
play the move Bishop d3 and try to trade
off another act of peace for black you
could still go for moves like a four
trying to gain space on the Queen side
you could even consider playing moves
like c4 but now you do have to be a
little bit cautious because c4 might be
losing tactically this is the other part
of chess that you do have to get good at
so c4 of course undefended the d4 pawn
and you might run into a little bit of
trouble with this file opening up now in
front of your deep one so once again
these are just some ideas to be tossing
around this is what you should be
thinking about in positions like these
this is how you can come up with logical
plans to improve the pieces now here
unfortunately for whites I don't think
many of these thoughts we're going
through this players head and ABI
unfortunately played the move Knight h4
which of course is losing this night due
to Queen takes h4 so how can we avoid
playing moves like Knight h4 well one
move blenders are always going to happen
they happen even at very very high
levels of chess but blenders like these
don't necessarily have to happen because
Knight h4 even if black were unable to
capture this Knight
it's just not a very good move we don't
want a sideline or night like this we
like improving our pieces to squares
like a 5 to outposts in the center or
deep in the opponent's camp whereas the
move Knight h4 doesn't really help us do
much of that at all
it also violates this principle that I
just talked about we're loose pieces
drop off so on e5 this is a nice square
for the knight the Knights very well
defended on h4 of course nothing
defending this Knight it makes you a
little bit more susceptible to tactics
or in this case just a simple
of the piece and then I don't want to
spend too much time on this game because
many very good chess player was able to
convert this pretty naturally once he
was up material of course once you're up
material in chess it's a good idea to
trade so he used these threats against
the White King to kind of bait white
into trading some pieces so Bishop f3 to
block the checkmate we see captures
captures now queen a5 and white brings
this rook to the center which is fine 97
we see this Queen reroute a bit knight
c6 rook over to h5 and after some kind
of crazy moves
white just kind of threw away this pawn
once again even when you're down
material here it's good to try and come
up with plans so it seems like white
pushed all the pieces over to the Kings
side so white's idea is probably going
to be to go for some kind of King side
attack here with that in mind the move
f5 was probably a really optimistic
approach hoping that black would do
nothing and then you would be able to
take either on e6 or even g6 and now you
get to open up all these files in front
of the King but unfortunately of course
you do have to think you know when you
move up onto a square like this you have
to look at the pieces attacking it and
in this case this just picks up another
pawn for black so a better move here for
white probably would be a move like g4
trying to prepare an idea like f5 also
going for moves like g5 isn't the worst
idea ever here so you just want to play
moves that logically follow your plan so
if you want to go for a King side attack
you probably want to open some files in
front of the King the best way to open
files in front of a king is to do so
with your pawns you want to use your
pawns kind of as battering rams to take
out these other pawns and you can
imagine maybe a much worse player than
Vinnie might play a move you know one
kind of nonchalant move like knight c6
here and all of a sudden he might be
getting in very serious trouble
after a few inaccurate moves for example
let's say a six just totally relevant to
the [ __ ] position all of a sudden Queen
h3 and it becomes very difficult to
defend the King's side I played through
those moves pretty pretty quickly here
and black played very very bad moves to
make this work
but the idea was we want to open things
up a little bit
get at this King break into his fort and
then after a few more moves we see h6
is a difficult plan to defend Queen h3
and black I think might actually just be
dud lost here despite being up a full
night so some things we learned from
this game 1 this idea of coming up with
a plan right on to the opening to this
rule for the night you want to put them
on outposts rooks go on open files or
half open files and pawns they can be
used sort of as these battering rams to
open things up either open a file for
the rook like we saw with c4 on the
Queen side in this case open files in
front of the King to try and go for an
attack very very quickly the game
continued with Knight f5 they got a
little bit crazy here and that came back
to d6 we saw the C file open up now g5
and Queen b1 check wasn't nice move by
Vinnie and now after a few more checks
we see this King simply run out of
squares and get checkmated on d3 so
unfortunately this game did not go
Abby's way of course Vinnie a very very
strong player not going to be easy to
take down without some of these
strategic principles all right I'm gonna
open it up to questions now regarding
this game regarding any of those basic
strategies we talked about once again I
think the live audience is generally a
little bit above this level but what
does it do a more beginner based lecture
are these online ratings yes I'm sorry
these are online ratings I believe Abby
has not played any standard USCF chess
in her life and I think Vinnie is
actually getting getting quite a high
USCF rating these days 1700 USCF I think
he crossed 1800 at some point but he
might have dropped back down
okay looks like not a lot of questions
where the game reviews so funny just
because I am such a funny guy new to
this so you need things a little bit
slower fair enough fair enough time
control I believe the time control it
was game in 10 minutes with no increment
this is for a beginners just a slightly
less advanced lecture for today so okay
I'm actually going to go through this
game very very quickly one more time
stopping at the key points to explain
the principles so we have this opening
which was played very well by both
players then we have this position here
where we need to come up with and what
with good ideas for us so one big idea
is to improve the pieces Knights belong
in outposts that's how we came up with
ideas like these and the move rookie one
other ideas are to gain space this is a
good way of playing chess this is a good
plan to go for the plan of gaining space
by moving your pawns forward on the
Queen side and there's this plant of
just solidifying your structure making
sure all your pieces are defended this
is not a bad way to play chess either
and then from there we saw this
unfortunate mishap by by white okay
those are the important parts hopefully
those are sticking with you let's move
on to game two this is a game also
between Vinnie and Abby of course this
was a test event and we had the players
to play two games with each other so
let's see how this goes for a beat now
with the black pieces the move
efore was Vinnie's choice E 5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop b5 we see a six now by
black pretty normal royal Pez so far
Knight f6 getting developed castles and
then black plays a fairly strange move
here at Bishop d6 and this is not the
worst move in the world actually and the
way the black followed it up was pretty
standard for how Bishop d6 players
usually approach this position if you
are watching and you're at a little bit
of a higher level the idea of Bishop d6
is usually brought out against
this early d3 in early d3 is usually
when players go for Bishop d6 after the
move castles and Bishop d6 who looks
like d4 are kind of immediately playable
in the ideas of a quick d4 I think are
the reason why Bishop d6 isn't played
until this pawn is committed to d3 but
we're not really concerned about all
that for this lecture we're concerned
about black getting the pieces out so
Bishop d6 d3 black now castles c3 and
black note needs to find a way to
develop this bishop so if you're
watching at home try and find a way to
develop this bishop now that you've
unfortunately blocked off your deep on
with this Bishop of course we know a
pretty natural way of developing this
Bishop usually goes something like this
let's say p5 is played d6 and now this
bishop can come out along this diagonal
but due to this Bishop on d6 it comes a
little bit harder to get this Bishop out
in sorry castles in c3 we're both both
played
so chests bobble one two five has the
answer
you play the move b5 this Bishop
retreats all the way back to c2 and now
you can bring this Bishop out to be
seven and this is not the worst position
in the world for black it's not the most
standard way of organizing your pieces
but we can't really expect the beginner
level players to play optimally in the
opening in this case black has developed
all of her pieces and that's about as
good as it gets
rook e1 was White's choice and this is
an improving move from white White has
an idea with this move why it wants to
play the move d4 and have this pawn be a
little bit more protected so this is why
rook e1 was played black or sorry white
rather playing moves with the purpose
and now black actually played a really
really nice move that it's kind of
indicative of a higher level of chess
than you expect so things look pretty
awkward for black now it's true that
black dot all of the pieces developed
and got castles safely and so you could
kind of say this is where the opening
ends for at least more beginner level
players and we're now firmly in the
middle game so we need to come up with
some middle game ideas so what are the
ideas we saw from game one well you can
one try to improve your pieces to try to
gain some space or three try to open
things up using your pawns using your
pawns to open files and open things up
generally hopefully in a favorable way
for you so who at home can come up with
some moves now that hopefully will lead
you to playing towards one of these
plans improving the pieces gaining space
or opening things up in a way that is
good for you
try and come up with some moves here
so diem says the justification is you
play rook e8 in Bishop f8 and then go
for a quick d5 this this is also
potentially true I just for some reason
think that an early d4 is still the way
to play against this plan the point of
Bishop d6 is also you are defending this
pawn adequately early on in the opening
and then later you want to bring it back
to f8 and it's just the same as if this
bishop I come into e7 and then back to
f8 so that's part of the idea with
Bishop d6 but we're not so concerned
with that here right now we are
concerned with the position in front of
us going in cold when you want to come
up with a plan for black to improve the
pieces gain space open things up one of
these three kind of things okay we are
getting some ideas coming in Sarah says
97 then c5 mousette Jones says Bishop c5
Bishop g5 that's an idea for white we're
trying to look from blacks perspective
here although it is good to see some
ideas for your opponent as well b4 has
been offered another vote for Bishop c5
and so no one has actually guessed the
move played in the game but they have
found the same idea as the move played
in the game so a really common idea for
black in the Royal PES structures is to
try and gain a little bit of space on
the Queen side which is what was played
in this game and that is a perfectly
fine way of playing so you guys also
have some good ideas the move h6 has an
idea that I haven't really talked about
yet so I've talked about improving your
own pieces gaining more space for
yourself and opening things up for you
but what I haven't talked about are some
preventative moves so each six is a what
we call prophylactic move in chess it's
a preventative move the reason being it
might be a little bit awkward for black
let's say you do nothing this Bishop g5
move might be a little bit awkward for
black when of course there's a pin on
this night pinning the knight to the
Queen that's a basic tactical motif
which hopefully you know going in
this lecture so age six would be a nice
preventative move to just avoid this
bishop from ever touching this g5 square
age six though does have its downsides
does have its downsides as well okay
so yet 97 to g6 is a pretty good idea so
these are ideas to improve the pieces so
the f4 square is actually going to be a
common outpost for Knights in the Royal
Lopes so that's why people want to put
this night on e7 they just found this
path they can go from e 7 to g6 and from
there that can come up to f4 and this is
a good outpost because this Knight is
defended on f4 and it attacks a lot of
important squares both in the center and
on the Kings side so not a bad idea at
all not a bad idea at all
the move before has also been suggested
and this is not really a bad move either
it might not be the best move in the
position but we're not so concerned
about that we're concerned with finding
purposeful moves moves that have purpose
in this case b4 aims to open the B file
and get this rook on a better square
which is a perfectly fine purpose so
before a purposeful move and so in my
opinion a good move here for black the
move played in the game and was not
Bishop c5 I'll talk about b5 as well
Bishop c5 well it does look like it
improves this Bishop this Bishop is
actually serving an important role kind
of defending this e5 pawn and so Bishop
c5 looks like it improves the bishop but
it's a little bit artificial here so
what I mean by that is that the bishop
looks better but in reality it doesn't
do all that much more and in fact if you
take a look at your opponent's plant if
you kind of flip flip the script here
and find a good move for white we'll see
that white has played c3 Knight f3 and
is likely planning to play this move d4
and e4 would likely be White's response
to Bishop c5 and after d4 of course
we're gonna have to move this Bishop
again and I'm not so sure if we're happy
about giving up this pawn just yet don't
know if we're totally ready to sacrifice
this pawn on e5 so Bishop c5 I'm not
gonna say is the best idea here
the move played in the game was actually
none of these moves suggested but it was
the move Knight a5 and I'm not gonna
call net a 5 a bad move because of how
black followed it up like followed up
very naturally white played at night bt2
and then of course the idea here for
black with Knight a5 was to get this
Knight out of the way so that we could
gain space on the Queen side so 95 c5
gaining space this was the plan for
black which makes 95 a good move in my
opinion all I want from you guys just
starting out here is moves with purpose
and that's what Knight a5 and c5 is
gaining space on the Queen side also
helping to prevent this pawn from moving
to d4 no Knight f1 was played and the
move rook e8 comes on the board as well
now rook e8 I'm not gonna get mad at
this move either rookie it controls the
center and is eyeing the fact that white
likely wants to play this d4 move and we
would like to have a little bit more
support for our 5 pawn or re 5 square in
fact if this move d4 ever does come on
the board so if Ricky eight an improving
move but also one of those prophylactic
preventive moves as well
controlling e5 a bit more Nigeria now
comes on the board so Vinnie of course
is well aware of this maneuver we talked
about at for being an outpost conversely
the square on f5 is also going to be a
good outpost for white
why can't white just go be four then
white gained space on the queenside
and black has to go back well here black
actually has the benefit of being the
first to the party so to speak so black
played c5 and when I say gaining space
c5 gained space in that it controls
these squares in the white camp that
black wouldn't have controlled otherwise
so maybe here the move b4 would have
been considerable because now if you
play before it the knight does have to
retreat as you said and that might be a
good line for black for white but rather
after Knight d2 c5 here if white were to
play the move b4 well things are a
little bit more awkward now because of
course like I said black was first to
the party and so with c5 we already
control this be for square and white
would actually have to put in a lot more
prep before he could actually play this
move thanks to our pieces already being
here to control the be four square I
also want to mention that gaining space
is good but sometimes pushing upon too
far can have some negative repercussions
as well of course the farther forward a
pawn goes the further in a way the
further away it is from its own pieces
from its home from its safety the closer
it is to attacking pieces and the more
potentially weak it becomes so this poem
b2 is pretty safe back there but a pawn
on b4 can pretty easily be attacked even
if this night had to return by the black
pieces for example this Knight now on c6
does attack b4 as well if we didn't have
this move Bishop takes b4 so okay so c5
was played in f1 Ricky eight is a fine
move in H III now
and now b4 sorry I skipped a little bit
ahead there be four from black is the
natural follow-up actually to the moves
that have been played so far we see
black playing it for the space on the
Queen side before is a perfectly natural
way to follow it up before also looks to
open files on the Queen's side why is
that better for black than white while
black is the one with more space on the
Queen side thanks to these moves and in
general it's good to open things up
where you have more space so let's say
vini weren't such a good chess player
here and then you play to move like
back to f1 now you can imagine black
would take on c3 maybe play a move
Bishop c6 and aim to get a rook on this
nice open file and I think this would be
a really comfortable position now for
the black player of course Vinnie is a
good chess player so he didn't play the
bad move Knight of one instead he took
this opportunity to counter an attack on
the wing with a push in the center so he
does now play this move d4 with this
Knight has a little bit of a extra
backup for this e5 pawn the move
he takes d4 comes on the board which is
a pretty interesting one white responds
with C takes d4 this was kind of the
point of whites play and oops my leaders
chest got study so he got my steps one
probably gonna have to skip ahead here
but okay C takes d4 so 64 was played C
takes d4 in exchange and now black got a
little bit stuck on what to do here just
play the move C takes d4 which is still
perfectly fine resolving the tension in
the center Queen takes d4 by white now
and if you are the player with the black
pieces here I'm not gonna lie to you you
have been outplayed a little bit by
white and that's down to Veni just
having tons and tons and tons of extra
experience in these positions and so
white does have a pretty good position
here
despite blacks moves being fairly
logical black played logical chest
purposeful chess and because of that I
think black isn't losing here black is
just a little bit less comfortable
because Vinny has actually played this
game pretty darn well
with that in mind let's try and come up
with something to do for black hopefully
you noticed that your bishop is attacked
so you do have to do something about
that but what can you do now with black
to try and continue improving your
pieces improving your position
Bishop f/8 has been suggested nanny has
pointed out a tactic that doesn't quite
work so I'll cover that in a moment but
I'll give you a second to think about
this position first
Queen c7 counter-attack has been
suggested
Bishop takes g3 Queen f7 I assume they
mean queen yz7
or maybe Queen c7 I don't know Queen c7
is what they meant this should fix g3
and then knight c6 so you guys are
coming up with some really good moves
here unfortunately for black the move
Bishop e7 was what she chose in the game
and this isn't a bad move by any means
it's tough to get too mad about the move
Bishop e7 but it does waste some time
right we have this idea of time and
chess of spending time a KA spending
moves to get positions and so we spent
one move one unit of time a tempo per se
to play Bishop d6 and now we're spending
another unit of time another tempo
playing the move Bishop e7 wasting a
little bit of time so in fact the moves
like Bishop takes g3 here are going to
be a little bit better than the
alternative for black move Queen c7 is
also a fine move for black rather than
spending more time getting bringing the
bishop back we spend one hour time
instead to bring the queen up attacking
a bishop and we kind of get to preserve
these threats on on the g3 square so
those moves would have been good but the
move Bishop e7 was played instead and
this was just a small thing I did want
to introduce to you guys as well this
idea of spending too much time on your
moves not actual time but spending too
many moves can be pretty detrimental in
in chess
so Bishop e7 wastes a little bit of time
and now white gets to develop pretty
naturally with the move Bishop f4 wait
it's not doing anything special not
trying to kill his opponent immediately
just getting all the pieces out which is
perfectly fine black now played a good
move which was rook c8 bringing a rook
to an open file White responded in kind
with a move rook c1 and now black went a
little bit off the deep end here and
just kind of gave up a rook for no
reason but assuming black doesn't do
that what kind of moves can you guys
come up with here it looks like a
radically different position than what
we started with but we can still fall
back on these ideas where we want extra
space we want
to improve our pieces and sometimes we
want to open things up using our pawns
so let's try and come up with a few
ideas for black here
oh sorry I I do want to mention before I
ask you this question
the movie 5 was brought up here luckily
while this pawn is forking the black
pieces we do have this in-between move
Bishop takes f3 attacking a queen and
then after such a move the move Bishop
takes e5 can come on the board in fact
the same idea happens here and after
Bishop e7 e 5 is a playable move and is
a pretty good move but it does give
black in this d5 square for a moment and
so black could consider staying alive in
this position and that being said II
five is a perfectly good move for black
for white in that position instead of
Bishop f4 okay
so some moves are being suggested now we
have the move knight c6 on the board we
have Bishop c5 not on the board but in
the chat rather so Bishop to c5 knight
c6 rook c4 has been suggested a lot of
moves on the C file somehow
Knight c3 I'm assuming that means Knight
c4 but okay okay I like it Bishop c5
there's one move in particular that I'm
waiting for you guys to point out let's
see if you guys can find it I'm not even
sure it's a good move here but it's
definitely a move worth considering this
is the type of move where if you can
play it and it's not bad
then blackheads probably solving a lot
of her problems immediately
so yeah the move d5 is something else do
you want to consider and once again I'm
not saying it's a good move here but
this is something you should always
consider in positions like these at
least so I like almost all the moves you
guys suggested move Bishop c5 looks
really good for black you get this
Bishop on a nice square here you get to
attach some squares on this side of the
board for example Queen back to d2 you
can even start considering things like
Knight g4 but also from here you can
just kind of solidify your position play
move like d6 guard this square and your
pieces don't look so bad after all
no this pawn on b4 is actually really
important for the black player here this
pawn we're somewhere like b5 suddenly
moves like b4 for white become available
so we see the space it is actually good
for something in this case it's
preventing some really important moves
for white the move knight c6 also makes
a ton of sense
this Knight out on a 5 got out of the
way so we could push our C pawn forward
it's kind of served its purpose there
and bringing back home to the center
seems like a perfectly natural way to
play as well it also gains time on this
Queen as the did the move Bishop c5
Brooks c4 not a bad move either I like
this one a little bit less than the
other ones just because I rooks kind of
floating out in mid space here it's
becoming a slightly loose piece and like
we said loose pieces can and drop off
sometimes you can follow it up with good
moves like Queen c8 but once again this
this rook just doesn't feel so
comfortable out here leading the charge
against the white pieces could get into
trouble but okay in the game black
played Rex 62 which is just a bad move
obviously rooks worth more than bishops
that's one principle you can normally
rely on but those were all good
improving moves as for the move d5 I
brought this move up not because it's a
really good move here but because it's
an attempt to kind of take away all of
White's pressure so while black gained
space on the Queen side due to these
fancy pawn exchanges that happen in the
center white actually has more space in
the center and space in the center is
just more valuable than space on the
side of the board because piece is
placed in the center
better than pieces placed on the side
this much we know so since white has
this extra sense a central space if
black in a dream world could play d5
white could take and black could take
all of a sudden in this extra space for
white would be gone and black would have
a great position kind of out of nowhere
unfortunately for black captures are not
forced in chess and so the move you have
to look out for when you play the move
d5 is going to be this move e5 and I
think II five would be a really good
move here for white unfortunately as
such
d5 might not be the most working
although you can't do funny stuff like
94 and really kind of go for it here
okay so I wanted to bring up this move
d5 because this is another good type of
move another purposeful move you want to
challenge your opponent's space
sometimes
so these moves all improving the pieces
which is one of those big three things
that I brought up at the top of the hour
and so these are all good moves but okay
rook takes c2 and once again the rest of
this game is kind of nonsense
b3 was a fine move trying to get this
Knight back into the game via the B 3
square we see Queen C 3 can be six
Bishop e3 and unfortunately more
material falls due to these exchanges
and then from here he 5 rooks e 1r x t7
and Rourke c8 is a checkmate
unfortunately for white so a couple
really instructive games at the beginner
level that I wanted to go over here from
a be in Vinnie next I wanted to step it
up just a little bit to to a slightly
higher level in the next game I'm gonna
look at is a game between the one and
only Denis the route and Adi Honda so
this is another game between a st. Louis
Chess Club staff member and a local st.
Louis chess playing child as I call them
Adi another member of our select chess
program one of those talented youngsters
trying to get better chess and showing
that it's working by beating up on the
staff so let's see how this game went
for it Denis really quick and I did say
we were stepping up the level of play
ever so slightly and while these ratings
on the screen it might not show
these are their chests calm ratings
Dennis is a much more experienced
tournament player tournament chess
player than Abby although Adi is a
little bit worse than than Vinnie so
this is a much more even matchup I will
say so let's see how this game went d4
d5 Knight c3 Knight f6 so these players
know a little bit about French theory
Bishop g5 now Bishop e7 e 5 drives this
night away 9 ft 7 Bishop takes e7 Queen
takes e7 and then white plays the move
Queen g4 so I wanted to ask you guys at
home what you think about this move
Queen g4 is this a good move is it a
typical move in the French but not good
here is it an atypical move but good
here
bad move good move what do you guys
think tell me all about this move queen
g4
these are a chest calm readings Dennis a
much stronger player than his rating
would have you believe I believe it was
a new account on chess calm
so nobody seems to think it's a good
move too early no help from the other
pieces pointless a typical move for the
Queen I don't know but it's kind of out
there so queen g4 is a pretty typical
move in a lot of lines in the French
defense the idea being it's not so easy
to respond to this move attacking in
this pawn on g7 sometimes why it's
playing this move to bate black into
castling because if black does castle
then he's going to get met with a really
strong attack on the Kings side
other times white will play this move to
try and bait the move g6 because of
course g6 weakens dark squares every
time you move upon it can never move
backwards and so it can never attack
these squares that had attacked on the
g7 square so sometimes white plays it
for this in this case though queen g4 is
a little bit too early and black just
simply castles now and white isn't quite
so ready to commit this Queen out to the
g4 square castles is a natural move for
black here and black also has the added
advantage of taking off these dark
squared bishop s' the c1 Bishop ending
up trading itself on e7 and so if this
bishop we're still alive
the move Bishop h6 would be a really
strong move here unfortunately or white
that Bishop is dead
so castles is a good move and now white
continues with the move h4 and this is
not what you want to do Dennis at a
maybe a higher level of chess and then
Abby knows more about chess than Abby
knows what he should be doing here goes
immediately for a King side attack but
that's not really what you want to be
doing there's this phrase that says a
bad plan is better than no plan at all
but that phrase does not say a bad plan
is better than not developing your
pieces and so here because dennis has
not fallen back on those opening
principles that we saw being followed to
a tee in those first two games he
already has a lost position white is
much much much worse here and black with
accurate play should be able to very
much win this game
now those are some bold claims from
myself here so I want to see if you guys
at home can see what I see see if you
can find how to gain a winning advantage
with black from this early opening
position and everybody is already
actually saying it what factors should
you look for to determine when it's okay
to advance your kingside pawns this is a
good question I'll talk about it in a
bit in a bit
he's looking for glory his pieces are
not developed yet so everybody seems to
have it the idea for black here is while
white is wasting his time not getting
these pieces developed black has wasted
no time spending every move with a
purpose developing a bishop recapturing
developing a queen castling the king
developing a knight and then removing it
from the threat of capture so black
because he has not wasted any time here
is well equipped to challenge white
center and he does so with this move c5
which is a typical French idea and the
problem now for white is that he has not
had enough time to play moves like
Knight f3 defending these central pawns
and so one of these pawns is is just
gonna die here and that is the sad truth
of life before Dennis through so Dennis
took this opportunity to queenside
castle but now after the move Knight c6
it's quickly becoming a hopeless
endeavor to keep these central pawns
together net f3 was an attempt but now
after C takes d4 you see Knight takes d4
and 9t takes e5 so Dennis doing things a
little bit out of order and that is more
or less than the story of this game here
just because you do know a common plan
in the position doesn't mean that you
can just blindly go for it you need to
spend each move with a purpose with a
good purpose and keep in mind what your
opponent is gonna be doing here so
Dennis's mistake going for this plan of
a King side attack too early trying to
use the pawn to break open this fortress
but more important than that are
following these opening principles
making sure you get a good solid
position before going for this this kind
of attack so that's the mistake of this
game but the story does not end there
excuse me Knight takes e5 queen of 496
Denis inserted this very funny
Intermezzo with Knight takes c6 of
course now if Knight captures Queen we
would have Knight captures Queen
so Adi simply recaptures on c6 there
with B takes
six Queens III now from White Queen f6
by black King b1 and now I want to kind
of flip the script here Dennis is trying
to survive with the white pieces he's
lost his Center so what can you do with
black to try and solidify your advantage
and and win this game of course in this
position black is up one pot just one
pawn but of course his position is a lot
better than then you would expect from
that so what's the best way to try to
win this game with black oh and sorry I
said I would answer a question and then
I didn't didn't answer the question so
while you're thinking on that I'll talk
a little bit about when it's okay to
kind of go for this craziness on the on
the kingside as Dennis tried to do in
this case generally you're gonna be
doing this when we have what's called a
closed Center a locked Center or you
have some extra central space as you do
in the French so when a Center is closed
that means that the pawns are sort of
locked together the pawns can't really
move and it's not so easy to open open
files open diagonals in the center by
removing those pawns it's tough to get
rid of those pawns so when the center is
closed like that that's kind of your
ticket to stop trying to play in the
center because the center is closed and
to start playing on the wings as Dennis
did in this game now the reason that
didn't work out for him is because the
center was not quite so rock solid so
closed as Dennis thought it was and so
the center kind of blew up and now his
attack on the Kings side is a little bit
less meaningful because missing these
pawns here it's not so easy to keep the
black pieces out as we see with this
Queen landing on f6 so that's just a
little verbal explanation for you
hopefully that makes sense on when you
can play for these kinds of Kings side
pushes and when you need to be a little
bit more more focused on the center okay
some ideas here some ideas we have c5
suggested a 5 V 5 V 5 a 5 in Bishop ace
I assume get our Bishop out to a3 and
right to be one I think you guys are
flipping the board a bit Bishop out to
a6 and rook to b8 as what I think you're
saying so there are a few different
approaches you can take here and just to
kind of explain what I think you guys
are getting at you know of course it's
it's tough to kind of explain all your
ideas in YouTube chat but I can kind of
tell by the moves you're suggesting one
idea for black is when you have extra
central pawns like this a really useful
way to you know kind of make them felt
make your central advantage felt is to
push them a little bit forward since
there's no pawns kind of opposing these
pawns the coast is kind of clear for
these guys to advance a little bit and
start controlling more squares in the
white camp so the movie 5 is a perfectly
fine improving move for black now the
move
c5 then with a 5 the move rook b8 we're
all kind of suggested here I will
mention rook b8 not great immediately as
the square is covered by the Queen so
it's gonna take a little bit of prep
work to get that done but these moves
are all with the idea of coming after
this king and this is another great way
that black can play here black kind of
has this benefit of just being up to
these central pawns for nothing in
return which means black can use the
central pawns 1 to try and push forward
in the center but also to to play on
this Queen side when he doesn't really
have to worry about the center at all
because he has such a dominant advantage
there there's one more idea that black
went for in this game to try and win and
this is sort of the least technically
good approaches I will say it's a very
practical approach to trying to win a
chess game but it's not something that's
for example like a computer engine would
would tell you is the way to play here
black understanding that white was still
going to try to push forward and win the
game on the kingside decided he just
wanted to simply try and trade down some
pieces here with the move Queen f4 and
while Queen f4 is not a terrible move
not a bad
it may be a little bit misguided here a
lot of players kind of operate under the
assumption that if they can win a pond
they can win the endgame you know one
pond isn't enough to win the endgame
that's not always the case here and in
fact some of these end games that black
offers to white by taking off these
Queens are not going to be as easy to
win as you might imagine so that's
something I wanted to kind of warn
against if you're up a super significant
amount of material if you're up a
full-piece for nothing if you're up like
two three pawns then you can kind of
take this approach where you just want
to trade off pieces get rid of all the
complications and win in the endgame
that's a great approach there but when
your advantage is only like one pawn you
might be letting your opponent off a
little bit easy by going for these kinds
of traits that being said dennis avoided
the trade with Queen D 3 and now 95
makes a lot of sense from aadhi bringing
this knight towards the Queen side Queen
e2 from Dennis still stubbornly avoiding
the traits and now rook b8 by black so
because white has declined all of these
trades black kind of got the freedom to
improve his pieces a little bit no
obviously this b8 square no longer
attacked by the Queen it's pretty
significant so Rick B it is nice
remember rooks belong on open or half
open files and it's putting a lot of
pressure on the white king here now rook
h3 by white is trying to develop this
piece one way or another in Knight c4 by
black and while we are playing chess at
a slightly higher level than those first
couple games you see that black is now
really going back to those basic
strategic principles because those are
just going to be the best moves in a lot
of cases c4 is a nice outpost for this
night
so you improves the knight by bringing
it to an outpost improves the rook by
bringing it to a half-open file and it
just so happens that these pieces have
the added benefit of attacking the White
King b3 now by white is an attempt to
relieve some of this pressure on b2 and
black responded now with E 5 so White's
or black is kind of getting it together
here playing all these moves and that
you guys are suggesting initially just
after offering some of the
traits rook f3 was played in the game of
course 'if I've attacked this rook
so the rook moves out of the way now we
have Queen takes h4 rook over to g3
Bishop up to f5 great chess so far by
black King a one night a three Queen
takes a five now and this is where white
our black starting to go a little bit
wrong in my opinion
here this is the type of position that a
lot of players look at and they say well
okay all right you know I'm still up a
full clean pawn because I got to take
this guy on h4
I'm just going to play super calm super
conservatively here and hopefully I can
win the game because of my extra pawn
because of that Adi played this move
Bishop g6 I think just an objectively
better move is to go for Knight takes c2
here when after this King moves it's
true that things get a little bit more
complex for for both players but I think
this is just a better way of playing now
for black of course if you don't see a
direct follow-up to this for black you
don't really want to play this way but
it's worth looking and it's worth trying
to find a direct follow up because if
you let your opponent get away with too
much
suddenly those concessions start to add
up and you might not even have a winning
position anymore just for example I
think a natural follow-up to this for
black would be just to play Bishop g6
and a FERC takes g6 we can simply take
this with the F pawn King takes and
things are gonna go downhill pretty
pretty quickly here for for white one
way or another block is just kind of
crashing through and there's small two
pieces for rook advantage that white
could've gained is not worth all of the
pawns that are dropping and the lack of
King's safety here so I think Knight
takes c2 would have been good for black
instead though the move Bishop g6 comes
on the board not bad at all
and now Bishop d3 and now there actually
is no reason not to take on c2 here you
can just bring the knight out your
Bishop isn't even you know threatened to
lose instead though rook e8 Queen b6 and
then Adi plays this move Queen East 7
you know not wanting to go for takes and
c2 at all just absolutely at all costs
please let's trade Queens and
unfortunately after Queen f4 Queen e5
Queen d2 Knight b5 King b2 the bad news
here for black is that he finally got
his wish
after takes takes takes and takes we see
the bishops come off the board as well
and all of a sudden black finally got
this endgame that he was fighting so
hard to attain but I'm not even
convinced that what that black is
winning in this position black did go on
to win the game because white had six
seconds left at this moment in time and
after a few more moves white simply lost
on time I believe Rick be8 was the final
mood of the game and why it lost on time
but in this position it's very very
unclear if black is even winning so let
this game be a little bit of a word of
warning to you number one while you do
while it is good to understand some
plans and your opening that's not an
excuse to avoid opening principles like
developing your pieces number two there
are many ways to win a chess game but if
you do want to just trade down and
simplify make sure you actually have
enough to win the game after that
simplification hopefully you guys
enjoyed the slightly more beginner
focused lecture I know a lot of you guys
in the chat are used to slightly higher
level lectures but I wanted to give this
beginner lecture a try after seeing
these games today hopefully you enjoyed
if you're watching live we are going to
have an endgame class directly after
this one so be sure to stick around for
that if you're watching the video thank
you so much for joining me my name is
Caleb Ben me and I will see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you